You know, the point about taking these pictures is
to tell a story, to communicate. Don't try to
win an art contest. Don't try to win a
photography contest. Don't have artistic lighting that puts some things
in shadow or in the dark. We want to show
the design features. What's really important for the designer to
understand, or for you to tell the story to
your audience? So let's take a, let's take a look.
Here's a picture of a train station. I wanted to
show that accidental social cues can serve as signifiers. You
know when you rush to the train platform, how do
you know if you missed the train? Well if there
are people waiting, you probably didn't miss it. If it's
empty, oops maybe you did. So to tell the story
I had to get to the train platform long before
the train was scheduled to arrive, carefully lean against the post
sign, wasn't going to change my position, and take pictures
as the people arrived. More and more pictures, because
I didn't know when the train would come. When
the train finally came, I then waited until the
train left and the platform was empty and I
took the last picture. Was it worth it? Yes.
To tell the story of the destination control elevator,
took a lot of pictures and some editing. And even
editing a label to understand the picture The photos
took a lot of work with a photo application, because
I had to crop the photos. So you could put
them together properly. And I cropped the photos, so when
I wanted to show the controls, you saw only
the control and nothing else that was distracting. So, four
different pictures tell the story. But once again, it was
worth it. Sometimes a single photo is enough to make
the point. You don't always have to have a
sequence of photos. So here's one, a picture of push
and pull doors. Same hardware in both doors, yet one
is push and one is pull. I crop the original
photograph and I darkened the glass, so the objects
behind the window were not as visible. That's okay to
do. It would not be ethical to fake it. To
put objects in that really weren't in the scene, or
to take away things that really were present.